how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and just when you
thought it couldn't get even more
confusing with Sony spider-verse and
spider-man in the MCU Sony comes out and
announces a new spider-man film this is
going to be written by the same people
that brought you the amazing spider-man
2 so we're going to break down
everything that you need to know if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to
Marvel and to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 so
this news is coming to us from the rap
and Collider and they are reporting that
a new spider-man spin-off movie is
coming from Sony and writer Roberto Orci
now Roberto wrote the amazing spider-man
2 that had Andrew Garfield spider-man in
it and now he's been tapped to write a
new spider-man spin-off movie one that
is currently in pre development over at
Sony now according to this report /
Collider we don't know much about this
movie we don't know which characters
it's going to revolve around or focus on
but we do know that this is not going to
take place inside of the MCU it's going
to be in Sony's spider-verse
now this doesn't come as that big of a
surprise sony has been setting up their
spider-verse for quite some time we have
venom and venom 2's coming out soon
Morbius and reported our Nightwatch silk
and silver and black not to mention
Kraven the hunter and not to mention
that Spider Man seems to be jumping over
from the MCU to the Sony verse
occasionally as well now besides being a
writer for the amazing spider-man number
2 or see as written and co-written
Mission Impossible 3 the rebooted Star
Trek trilogy and the first - transformer
films and Sony seems to have a pretty
good direction in which they want to
take this new spider verse that they
have venom was a success you can't
really argue with that venom - is very
hype right now and the Morbius trailer
actually looked pretty dang good and
everybody's really excited for this
movie not to mention - see how it all
connects now of course we would like to
think that they could be bringing in
Miles Morales or maybe even a Spider
Woman movie that has been reported about
in the past and one has to think that
perhaps they are starting to develop the
live-action spider-verse spider-man into
the spider verse was a massive success
for Sony and it proved that they could
do spider-man on their own and now
they're making spider-man into the
spider verse 2
now luckily for us Sony and Marvel /
Disney have been playing nice lately and
both the CEOs of both companies have
expressed interest in continuing their
contract with each other after both new
spider-man films so it's pretty safe to
say that Tom Holland is going to remain
in the MCU however like I mentioned one
superpower that he seems to have is
being able to jump between the universes
between Sony and Marvel so the
spider-man that they're most likely
going to bring in in this film is most
likely not going to be Peter Parker
there are obviously many different
spider-man they can choose from or
spider-gwen or Spider Woman and then
they can have Tom Hollands spider-man
jump over to the Sony verse and complete
a live action spider verse again not
much is really known about this film but
one does have to think that this is
going to be their first step in
developing a live-action spider verse
but let me know what you think about
this awesome news which spider-man movie
would you like to see in which different
version of spider-man would you like to
see enter the Sony verse let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up-to-date on all
things related to Marvel and spider-man
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or ps4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof